hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 I've completely given up on
my hair I have no there's nothing I can
do about it that would make it any sort
of good right now but I'm here not for
my hair I am here to beat nightmare mode
and everyone's been telling me that this
is going to be unbelievably incredibly
stupidly hard and supposedly supposedly
it introduces a completely different
animal onic in it now I don't know what
it is I don't know how to beat it but I
imagine it's that question mark at the
end of the list of animatronic so I'm
gonna just approach this with the idea
that it's going to be very difficult I'm
gonna try my best I'm assuming is gonna
shift gears at one point or another and
then I'm just gonna move on okay
whatever let's do this let's do this
with a fiery vengeance
well I'm here steps tampering already
Louie yeah yeah you better back off
was that the screams of the children
already damn three of them already holy
hell okay here we go yeah okay someone's
a sprinting back and forth all over the
place
alright we're okay things are okay
things are probably okay okay children I
know I know calm down little kitties
it's gonna be okay mommy's here to throw
you into the closet and never remember
you yeah that's why I thought that's
what I shot no you get out of here
goddamn the screams of the Damned
children get out of here your bull heard
that
oh it's been a while since I messed up
one of those thought I heard of rebou
but I didn't because I'm full of poo I
should point out I don't know if I
points up version 1.02 one in between
the time that I played it earlier today
and in between now there's been an
update again and I don't know why I
mentioned that whatever I'm Didion
already want this woo come on wall you
one p one per French you want a one per
Wampus woo okay here we go on ik uh-huh
uh-huh tell me more about how you suck
yes right - I thought screams of the
damn children get out of here screaming
children screaming children Pat them a
little bit I don't know if he - milk or
something shut up again very late very
late okay don't like this house
definitely obvious foxy then screaming
children I know I know screaming
children is bad I'm a bad mama I know
take care of you I'll feed you in a few
days oh crap that's not enough on foxy
that was not enough what the [ __ ]
god dammit what a bunch of horse baloney
bunch of poopy dicks bunch of poopy
dicks I almost made it to 4:00 a.m.
which I'm assuming is when it was gonna
change over I was doing okay I was doing
okay just gotta focus
come on come on I'm on changeover
oh [ __ ] good [ __ ] [ __ ] okay just
stand up whoa what was that whoa that oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
Oh Oh me no likey oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god okay okay okay lose it
poor [ __ ] what oh my god what was that
what was that
well obviously that was a new one but
what the hell happened okay
so what I did I get wrong obviously
because when the laughs happened I
didn't even bother to check down that
hallway or else I would have been fine
what the [ __ ] balls holy crap okay okay
just changed over okay just changed over
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh Jesus come on
oh [ __ ] come on the [ __ ] oh what the
hell
goddamnit okay so when he laughs he
doesn't go into the closet is that what
I'm supposed to take from this I all
right so
oh here we go here we go here we go oh
boy oh boy here we go hmm Oh [ __ ]
balls and ass was that the ball [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] little boy okay that's
definitely inside all [ __ ] [ __ ] closet
closet come on
oh yes yes yes yes god damn it
yes ooh lucky flam whoa what am I
looking at here
whoa okay so oh my god okay so my first
thoughts on seeing this is throughout
the entire game like in fought whoa
perhaps some things are best left
forgotten for white okay that blew my
fury out the window I thought throughout
the game like in five nights at Freddy's
3 there were like hidden items and
hidden things and Easter eggs like two
keys that you could get so maybe that's
it but also Scott said that there was
going to be DLC for this game in
particular released on Halloween now
there is one more thing that it can be
found in this game that you guys need
know about and that you guys told me
about if I go to the extras menu and I
type this well I mean I'll show you in a
sec if I type 20 20 20 20 no maybe
oh snap
Austin is it a snap it's goddamn 20 20
20 20 mo night 8 holy [ __ ] you guys were
right there is there are nine eight
eight nights so let's just give this a
see cuz I don't know how tough that's
gonna be but I imagine it's going to be
very oh god damn it too early on it I I
heard footsteps in the right one but it
wasn't it was too early it was too early
god damn is before he actually left okay
so that's twenty twenty twenty mode I
don't know how hard that's gonna be to
beat it might not be as difficult the
original twenty twenty mode but oddly
enough I do not have time for it in this
session I'm actually going home because
tomorrow I'm recording this when this is
released it'll actually be my brother's
birthday if you didn't know my brother I
was just down with him at Comic Con he
is the author of the webcomic two kinds
I'll put a link in the description he's
a great great guy
I've no
my whole life and I love my brother to
death so I'm gonna celebrate his
birthday back in Cincinnati Ohio I'm
gonna see my friends I'm gonna see my
family I might try to record 20-20-20
mode when I'm in Cincinnati but I'd have
to play through the whole game again to
get to the point where I was so maybe
I'll get that when I get back but for
now I just want to have some closing
thoughts about five nights at Freddy's 4
this was a phenomenal success er this I
love the direction that Scott took with
this game the change from video to audio
is genius like well maybe not genius but
it's great because of what I was talking
about in like the first few episodes the
little moment of apprehension every time
you go up to a door every single time
you are able to feel this sense of I
don't know you know you know it's that
feel literally it's a feeling of I don't
know what's gonna happen I do not know
if I'm gonna die but I am forced to act
and if I don't act I will die I have to
act to save my life and I have to do it
right that is really really cool and a
really unique take on it and it makes
the formula which is the same it's the
same formula you know trying to survive
from animatronics coming to your door
but it takes that formula and it
presents it in a new way it is great
now I could have some critiques about
critiques about these animatronics in
that maybe they're a little too horrific
you know there's a point which oh that
was oh my god he's so vicious holy hell
look at that guy nightmares is his name
so there was nightmare fredbear and
that's just nightmare so I don't know
how this fits in the with the lore I
will leave that up to the game theorist
you know matpat I'll leave that up to a
whole bunch of people to debate the lore
of this but this was a great addition to
a great series of games and to be honest
there may be DLC at it and I want to see
how that uncovers more of the story and
I do not know what 2020 2020 mode will
add to the story I will find that out I
promise you but for now I like to say I
had
a great time playing this there were
some serious scares almost every single
time a scare happened it got me like I
very you know in the last few games I
became numb to it after a while but even
up until the last episode this episode
it still got me and you may say one way
or another about jump scares but jump
scare is only good if the level of
apprehension comes before it and knowing
that the jump scare is a result of your
actions as opposed to ran this that's
good that's when it's good and the
atmosphere and the music and the sounds
all great I love this game I really hope
you did too let me know what you think
in the comments below there's one more
episode to go plus the DLC when it comes
out in Halloween thank you everybody so
much for watching check out the plethora
of all the other five nights at Freddy's
stuff that I've done the musicals the
compilation the interview the animations
all good stuff thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
boom